about maybe 15 people here
and 35 people on webex and as i
understand it they can hear
me quite well it can i don't know if
they'll be able to hear you guys
yeah can you turn the camera around so
we can see who's in your audience sure
hi everybody
yay
good to see people again that's great
that was a great side
to see you
okay
hello hello there's kate thanks bill
okay
good
okay so um
welcome everyone to our first um
in-person dmice conference
of the pandemic
of 2022 and i guess of 2021
um i always thought that when we would
have the first conference that i would
want to be the first one to present
so um i
took advantage of
my status
and
anointed myself the
first speaker but i i hope that um other
people will speak this way
and um
um you know things are looking pretty
good i'm uh ever the optimist uh david
door jokes that you know i get paid the
big bucks as department chair to be
optimistic um i actually don't get paid
that big of bucks but um anyways um
i'm optimistic that we'll be able to
continue moving um in this direction and
then i thought well okay if i'm going to
give a talk what i want to talk about um
some of you may have seen this um
article that was published late last
year
i was really enamored by it so enamored
actually i've had number of emails with
the author
and um have been encouraging him to
actually keep it up to date and um
one of the things that i really
like about this article
is that
well a few things you know one is that
um you know we've been saying for a long
time now you know machine learning ai is
going to impact medicine and this
article um
is a systematic review that attempts to
look at at what is actually
true and not or not true in that regard
and um
another thing that i like about this
article and i'll show you this in my
rudimentary powerpoint graphics is that
it actually covers all aspects of demise
because we have
clinical informatics so implementing
this in clinical settings we have
bcb
all the hardcore data science machine
learning modeling and so forth and
clinical epidemiology that doesn't
participate a real lot i was actually
hoping that maybe some
folks might come but the the folks up on
the fifth floor or well they mostly work
remote these days who uh do uh
systematic reviews um
in the and publish them in the
literature and so this uh really
encapsulates all three of these
and so um i i have um i don't have a
hey come on in i don't have a massive
number of slides here i i deliberately
wanted to keep this a little on the
short side um also for some discussion
because i actually think that demise is
really well poised to
you know carry on and contribute in this
way
of of making some of the newer advances
in machine learning deep learning and
all that
clinical reality benefiting patients
and so um
so my last slide is conclusions but i
actually it's sexy questions and it's
not my conclusions because i hope there
will be some interaction with the
audience
we'll see
how well that works in our somewhat um
updated um although all the cables here
are still those all the
video cables are still the old style vga
but anyway supposedly uh he told me
that's going to be upgraded so let me go
ahead and get started oh i guess i
didn't introduce myself since i usually
introduce the speakers but but everyone
knows me but if if you're out there and
you don't i am bill hirsch i'm the chair
of d mice and
the director of the biomedical
informatics graduate program and
actually i put these slides on my
website
i actually meant to send them out by
twitter
beforehand and i was changing things at
the last minute so i didn't do that and
so again hopefully there'll be some time
for discussion
so
let's see if we can get the
okay
so we're back to the office somewhat
so um uh in-person classes those that
have been scheduled to be in person uh
will be
and um you know of course many of our
health and clinical informatics courses
are online so those will continue in
that manner the fellows meeting which i
uh plan to attend today um and uh will
will also be in person
this conference um
when the speakers are willing to do as
i'm doing today they can speak in person
we streamed this conference for years
before the pandemic
we will continue to do that and that
will allow more people to participate
and in fact hopefully with better
technology it might be a little bit more
interactive than it used to be of people
having to when there were microphones on
the table push the button and and all
that other stuff um so we'll see how
that works if nothing else this speaker
will uh need to stream as always i do
want to tell everyone that as of now
unlike the last two years we are
planning to have graduation while ohsu
is planning to have graduation as always
d mice will be there we always are
i
pull out my regalia the last couple
years i've had to put it on at home um
and stand in front of a camera
including as some of you know two years
ago when my daughter graduated medical
school we actually got a picture of
myself her and the dean on my screen
talking and apparently the the dean
loved that picture so much she actually
showed it in her state of the school
address that year um anyways we also um
used to have a banquet and we're
planning to do that this year
lynn will be working on the details it
will probably be the saturday night
before graduation which will take place
on sunday june 5th
i will be there i've only missed one
graduation in the 20 or so years we've
had graduates because um
the i the nih insisted that i come to a
project uh meeting that unfortunately
conflicted with graduation but every
other year i've been there
so um faculty um are welcome now to
start returning to the office most
people like myself plan to do so one or
two days a week um i've actually been
coming in on a number of mondays
and i will continue that and probably on
thursdays as well um and of course
we're all very accessible by the usual
means um our office staff will
be returning to the office later but
they're also again very accessible by
email and other means um if you're like
me you may follow the covid um
statistics i guess it's being blocked by
the webex thing um but um you know ohsu
has i don't know if you've seen the ohsu
covid response website but um we're down
now to four patients in the hospital at
ohsu which really
i remember
a couple months ago was almost a hundred
and so we're making progress now we know
that there's the ba2 variant and so
forth uh but hopefully we'll stay at
that uh level so then that gets fast
that then that gets to the next question
about what about wearing mass um
wearing masks is optional
i still do it sometimes when i'm in
really crowded settings um i
well everyone theoretically is is at
least
vaccinated twice hopefully everyone
three
actually because of my age i'm actually
eligible for a fourth one starting next
week which i will probably do
i think the data is pretty impressive
so
mass are optional but certainly if
people ever ask me to do so i i will do
so so having a low threshold for for
wearing a mask so
okay well let me let me go on to um
my talk
uh so one kind of tagline for the talk
could be ai meets ebm evidence-based
medicine um or another one might be we
need to be doing ai beyond data
wrangling and modeling that's that's fun
many of us like to do it um but if we
really are true to the principles of
biomedical informatics we want to
um provide clinical value
so i'm going to give a little kind of
level setting background because um some
some of you may know a ton about machine
learning and very little about
evidence-based medicine or or vice versa
and um again i was hoping maybe there's
some of the folks on on the webex uh
from the uh clinical epi side of the
department so what this um
so that that will
i'll do that first i will then um
discuss this paper i will go through
some of the results
disclaimer i've done this a number of
times already i um
we as some of you know we have
colleagues in argentina they invited me
to their annual informatics conference
this past november unfortunately was
virtual because argentina is a great
place to visit which we used to do so
but i actually gave a
similar version of this talk without all
the extra demi stuff
but so the systematic review looks at
the clinical impact and quality of
randomized controlled trials involving
interventions evaluating ai prediction
tools
and then um some discussion really
mostly open end discussion open-ended
discussion at the end
about clinical evaluation of ai is that
something that we can or should be doing
so um
whoops
let me
guess i can't really
i can move these things like that
excuse me
so as you know there's three parts to d
mice there are the clinical epidemiology
folks that do evidence-based medicine
and systematic reviews upstairs
there are health and clinical
informatics which i consider myself to
be most closely aligned with focused on
clinical informatics systems applied ai
and machine learning
and of course bioinformatics and
computational actually that should be
biomedicine sorry
that do a lot of the omics work and a
lot of the deep diving into data science
and that there obviously is overlap i
was trying to decide how to draw that
venn diagram to look most effective but
the the the notion is that we can all
converge at that center
piece there and that is d mice
okay so this talk will address a topic
at this
intersection of the three areas of de
mice so we'll talk about a systematic
review that could have been done
in fact some of us in this room have
done systematic reviews of informatics
related topics uh myself included so
that's clinical epi folks
looking at the clinical aspects of
predictive ai tools so those of us in
hcin and then applying data science and
machine learning
which is some in hcin but
also definitely in bcb
so um here's one bit of level setting
around clinical epidemiology and
evidence-based medicine perhaps for
some of the bcb folks although maybe
they know all this already um so
evidence-based medicine ebm
many involved on the clinical side know
that it's applying the best evidence for
making clinical decisions and probably
the best reference is what's now called
the strauss book was originally the
second book that was written by david
sackett back
starting um in the
1990s yeah yeah and it was called the
second book but sackett accident
unfortunately he's passed away but he
retired a number of years ago um and
sharon strauss is now the lead editor so
um ebm evidence-based medicine prefers
experimental studies so studies where we
actually
manipulate things to see if something
works better than something else but we
can use observational studies which are
studies where
we don't manipulate things
experimentally but we do
um
observations that are
um
making the best use of data
so
um clinicians have many questions but
they generally fall into four categories
in each of these four categories has
different types of what's considered to
be the best evidence the best kind of
study so when we're talking about
treatment or even preventive measures
the best study is a randomized
controlled trial where we take a
population of people who are similar and
we randomize them into one group or the
other and
we've
we read about randomized control trials
in the news now with vaccines with new
covet treatments and so forth
um
that randomized control trials are the
gold standard for
um experimental
um determination of whether the
treatment or vaccine or something works
or a diet or anything else that we do
um when we we may have a question about
diagnosis actually a lot of clinical
predictive tools
including these ai tools um are looking
to
essentially make a diagnosis for example
a machine learning algorithm that's
interpreting uh chest x-rays
so we typically do some comparison with
the gold standard and with machine
learning we do
training data and test data maybe with
cross validation
to try to see what is the best method
that works generally
another big question is harm does um
something cause disease whether it's a
it's a virus or an environmental
exposure toxin or something like that
or something that we use to treat
disease and makes people better but also
causes harm
the best way to study that actually
would be a randomized control trial but
it's usually not ethical to do that for
something that's harmful so we use
things like cohort and case control
studies which i won't go into but those
are the kinds of studies that we look at
and then finally questions of prognosis
um so and there we use prospective
cohort studies so for all these studies
types
when there are sufficient number of
studies that are similar enough to each
other we can do a systematic review
which means we ask a focused question
and pull in all the evidence all the
studies um and that's what a lot of the
folks in the clinical
epi side of the department do
a few years ago i was involved with the
study actually on telemedicine before
telemedicine was actually really widely
used and our main conclusion was that
it's barely used that's not the case
anymore since the pandemic
and if these studies are very
homogeneous for example
18 studies of the same drug
to treat covid or high blood pressure
whatever
we can actually do a meta-analysis where
we combine all the data as if it's a
single study which increases statistical
power
um
so
they're uh in terms of
if there are any of the clinical epi
folks who are less familiar with
informatics but um certainly um so this
is another bit of level setting let me
see where we are time-wise we've gone a
little slower than i had hoped um
the
um so level setting around it
watch is talking to me sorry
um so one one of the major activities of
clinical informatics is applying ai to
patient care and some of us in this room
are old enough to have experienced the
first generation of ai that started with
people like ted shortlife
that was his phd dissertation at
stanford in the
i think was the early 1970s
um and the first generation of ai was
very different than the ai we do now
there was the development of handcrafted
knowledge basis so coming up with all
the rules or tables however we were
going to do that and then writing
computer programs that would work on
those rules or tables or whatever and of
course
some of us can also remember when
computers didn't have the kind of power
of my watch to start telling me where i
am
um or guys actually the internet's been
around a long time but but the real
robust high-speed internet and in fact
the the whole kind of first generation
of ai was not scalable
and there was
what some people call the ai winter
starting around the late 1980s which was
actually right at the time that i
started my nlm fellowship just like many
of you
um and in fact my interest in
information retrieval
came about in part because i saw the
whole ai
first generation ai world kind of
collapsing under its own weight and and
actually i mean people even stopped
using when people started using the term
ai again about five or ten years ago oh
i remember that term um anyways but now
of course ai is the big thing it's had
its resurgence in the 21st century and
it's really being driven by machine
learning and especially some of the
advances in deep learning machine
learning actually and even neural nets
existed back in the 20th century when i
was an
lm fellow um but again we didn't have
the data we didn't have the
computational power so there were very
small
um some would say toy systems
um but by
um
you know the the 2010s or you know the
or the aughts the 2000s now we were
getting large amounts of data both
generally and in medicine electronic
health records digital images things
like that
and then also having plentiful computer
power to process them and um
some of the um uh
then the development of deep learning
methods which many of you in this room
know more about than i do um have really
led to
impressive capabilities classifying
images classifying ekgs
classifying things out of medical
records and so forth
so we've made a lot of progress in that
regard but actually
as of 2022 we can ask the few folks in
the room who see patients the ai doesn't
impact their clinical practice much yet
and so um that's because we need these
next steps of of turning uh you know
taking the
um the models and and their results and
um finding ways that to show that they
actually improve clinical care
um so that brings us to data science and
machine learning there's a ton of
literature out there but you know data
science in essence being the science of
learning from data i love this quote
from this guy donahoe that a data
scientist is a person who's better at
statistics than any software engineer
and better at software engineering than
any statistician so you kind of need
both to do data science
and in fact you know some of us in
informatics have had angst around the
term data science and you know was that
different from informatics it's also
impact the impact of the statistics
field they're kind of grappling with um
you know do we do statistics or data
science
anyways but you know the big um
achieve
achievements have been machine learning
which um is attributed to
um arthur samuel in 1959
year after i was born
a field of study that gives computers
the ability to learn without being
explicitly programmed and that that
describes what machine learning does and
especially deep learning and um i
actually uh have a pdf of this talk that
um is is on my website and i'll i can
send the link around um there have been
some
um you know eric topel who was the
keynote speaker at last fall's amia
meeting has written a lot he wrote a
book in 2019 um uh raj per car i can't
remember his uh la his first name
published a paper uh this year um that
is a nice kind of overview of where we
are and where we need to go it's i think
it was published in in jama the medical
journal
and then we have this diagram which some
of you have seen me show before it comes
from our friend phillip payne um just
pointing out that there really is a
cycle
and um
one side of the cycle is where we go
from the real world to our knowledge
about it
and that and he calls this the afferent
process and afferent processes and data
science plays a big role here although
many people in informatics do this kind
of work too but where informatics really
differs from data science um is in the
efferent loop where we go from applying
knowledge back to the real world and
that's where some of the other things
that we do in informatics
that are listed here evaluation
implementation science organizational
theory human computer interaction
workflow etc so
it's a it's a big happy world and
hopefully we can
loop this cycle
and
have
things like machine learning and deep
learning provide care to patients
okay so let us ask then what is the
evidence for the benefit of ai i guess
it took me almost 20 minutes to get here
um so we think like we think in
evidence-based medicine we we want to
look at experimental interventions um
whether they're treatment or prevention
um probably coming from randomized
controlled trials um
randomized controlled trials can just
like any other kind of research can be
done poorly um so there are um best
practices for doing them so they should
be welcomed
their results should be generalizable
and well reported and it's really weird
that someone is talking and should be
muting themselves even though i'm
sitting here in this in-person
conference whoever is talking please
meet yourself um there are other
questions that we could answer ask and
answer about ai once again about
diagnosis harm and prognosis but
ultimately
we have to demonstrate that they benefit
um
someone patients clinicians populations
and so forth
and so that's what led to this
systematic review
by a team from a university in china who
i probably should have put it on here
but i didn't i just have the reference
this is an open access article so anyone
can go get it and read it
again i've had some emails with the
first author who's very um been very
helpful he actually um sent me some data
but what this um systematic review is
looking at is what are the randomized
control trials evaluating interventions
using
ai prediction tools
and is published in npj digital medicine
which is part of the nature
publishing group um and um
uh they did what the epc folks do
upstairs they they did a broad
literature search you'll see some
details of it
and and they basically um lumped the
randomized control trials they found
into three categories
which i think is reasonable
um one are the traditional statistical
methods that we don't typically
associate with machine learning even
though there is some learning going on
there there are then the kind of classic
machine learning networks machine
learning methods
and then there are deep learning systems
that use
complex uh neural networks
and so what what they found in general
was that the first two categories i'll
call them ts and ml focused on a variety
of things
um that um
they were used for assistive treatment
decisions so making decisions about
treatments to use assistive diagnosis
helping to make diagnosis and also risk
stratification we often in medicine do
risk stratification to decide if someone
is at risk for something and that may
lead us to intervene
um more so the
all of the randomized control trials of
deep learning and there's only 11 of
them
have focused on assistive diagnosis
which is not surprising and most of them
focus on imaging
so
keep going
okay so if you've ever read a systematic
review
um
you know you basically what you do is a
very broad literature search you go to
something like pubmed um they've
actually published as an appendix this
long
literature asserts that they did i think
it was pretty good usually the
um
at least the systematic reviews that are
done here they involve library staff who
are very knowledgeable about
using
retrieval systems and so they found 26
000 articles in the literature and
that's not surprising and in fact that's
fairly common in a systematic review
they remove duplicates they
screen the records but then because they
were looking for randomized controlled
trials they quickly got down to a tiny
number
and um
they
so what you do in a systematic review is
you screen the abstracts sometimes the
articles don't have abstracts so you can
only go with the title you can't read
the full text of every article
so but they did pull out 95
full-text articles that had um
that would were potentially randomized
controlled trials of um ai tools
and of those 95
trials
95 articles they identified 65
randomized controlled trials from 63
articles sometimes an article will have
more than one trial
and
those were included in the analysis and
they also were looking
i won't talk about it much but uh
observational validation studies so
studies that validated some of the
algorithms that were studied
in
in these um
the algorithms that were used
okay i'm going to keep moving the webex
stuff
it's okay
so
um
so they identified 65 randomized
controlled trials so this is a table
that unfortunately i probably could have
made it larger it's probably not that
visible so i would just highlight some
of the findings in the table so of these
65 trials
61 had 61
40 of 25 had positive results
so um so when there's a positive result
that means there was some benefit shown
for the ai so you can be a glass half
full or empty kind of person you can say
wait a second that means 39
38.5 of the trials did not have positive
results um
that's not uncommon when something goes
from
the laboratory the bench um to the real
world
and we can still learn things when a
trial is is not positive
um
[Music]
hello
sorry um
they looked um one other thing about
positive trials um we need to be careful
sometimes people look at well what is
the number of positive trials does that
mean that something is effective
that's actually not necessarily a good
thing because the trials are not
uniformly distributed over all the kinds
of questions that we would ask
so
it
the number 61 percent positive trials is
important to know but it isn't like the
analysis stops at that point
they looked at the disease categories
that these tools were applied to
cancer was fairly high especially the
imaging studies
other chronic diseases acute diseases
primary care
excuse me the um
type of algorithms
there were more traditional statistical
than machine learning than distance
learning than deep learning sorry
probably because
of the age uh
statistical tools have been used a lot
longer than machine learning and those
methods have been used a lot longer than
deep learning
and they looked at the predictive tool
function i mentioned this before
the most studies have been done on
assistive treatment decisions
more so than assistive diagnosis and
more so than wrist stratification
here's an issue though that came up and
this is
something that happens in all
um clinical studies not just ones of ai
um there were some concerns of what they
call you know risk of bias um if we do a
study perfectly
then its risk of bias should be small
but
if there are things that we do
such as not using the consort
statement which is a checklist of all
the things you're supposed to do in a
properly conducted randomized control
trial over 50 percent of the studies
didn't use the consort tri the consort
statement um three-fourths of the
studies had no masking so the people
applying the af tool
knew that they were applying it that can
bias studies that's why we it works best
with
pharmaceuticals but that's why we give
patients
placebos so that neither the clinicians
nor the patient know the drug that
they're getting unless they get certain
effects from it but but for the most
part that's the purpose of doing a
double-blind randomized control trial
a number of studies did not use intent
to treat analysis so
when you're doing a study
a randomized controlled trial you should
be analyzed in the group
that you're you were assigned to even if
you end up crossing over so like in a
surgical trial you may end up needing
surgery but
if you got randomized to the
non-surgical group you should your data
should be analyzed with that group and
then a lot of these studies didn't
provide details of their study protocol
so let me move on
let's move the
webex windows around again
um so that there's another table
that
looked at the characteristics by tool
type
and so you see
you should be able to see that a little
bit
the traditional statistical tools
the machine learning tools and deep
learning tools
and um
they they kind of sliced and diced um i
won't go through everything on the slide
but um
one interesting finding was that um
almost all the
traditional statistical machine learning
tools use clinical quantitative data so
basically structured data out of
electronic health records
not surprising most of the deep learning
studies used images
and
another interesting finding actually
kind of hard for someone who does
research with uh free text narrative
text is that i think only two studies
actually tried to use uh text in the um
in the machine learning models
and and there's big challenges in in
doing that um
and so in terms of disease category the
highly variable for traditional
statistical a lot of the machine
learning studies looked at
chronic disease and a lot of the deep
learning looked at cancer again mainly
because they were doing imaging
diagnosis
in terms of the results
um
they were
they were actually more positive for the
machine learning and deep learning
studies and and kind of mixed first
statistical although again counting
numbers of positive studies is not
really the best
way to say that some method works better
than another one
okay so
i'm going to just keep moving these
something we'll have to figure out how
to do as people give these talks
so
here they looked at
studies by year and there's
um probably no surprise here the um
traditional statistical although their
numbers go up over time um but you know
you don't see the appearance of deep
learning studies until the
later years 2019 and 2020 because
deep learning is a lot newer
the positive results
vary by year there's i don't know
there's any conclusions one can draw
there
in terms of actually and this is an
error here this should actually be type
of prediction tool
um
positive versus negative we we see that
the traditional statistical
uh
has um about a fifty positivity rate
it's higher for the machine learning
studies that that doesn't necessarily
mean that
machine learning is quote unquote better
but um the there are more positive
studies
here's where we get to the a little bit
more detail on some of the risk of bias
so they went through the 65 trials and
looked at various factors related to
risk awareness
so things like selective reporting
incomplete outcome data
the various kinds of blinding
another issue is allocation concealment
with that what that is is that you
prevent
the experimenters from possibly
manipulating the allocation um i can
remember when i was a medical student
that you used to randomize patients
by putting
things in envelopes and people would
hold the envelopes up to the like
because i really want to get the patient
into the experimental group and not the
control group but that that's actually
undermining your study because if you
get this all the sicker patients
in the experimental group then you know
they may just do more poorly and you
won't achieve the benefit that you would
get if you did truly random allocation
um
a lot of the studies
it's not that they didn't do these
things is that they didn't report it in
their studies so they may have done some
of these sorts of things but
they didn't describe it as well as they
should
um and um
we can see here that there are um
concerns about risk of bias
perhaps more so in these traditional
statistical studies but in all of them
across the board
and this is just more ways of slicing
and dicing the risk of bias
so what one other one
actually criticism i would make of this
paper not so much with the data is that
um
not so much with i mean the analysis
that they did but of how they presented
the data so for example
this is
and i wanted to cover these because i
thought people would be interested in
seeing what kind of deep learning
studies were done because we know that
deep learning has been used for many
many things but um almost um
all of the clinical randomized
controlled trials of deep learning have
you have focused on assisting endoscopic
procedures in particular gastro
gastrointestinal procedure so scopes um
if you're as old as some of us you've
had these procedures done
where they either put a flexible scope
down from the top or up from the bottom
um and actually there there is some um
there are some good studies that have
shown that if you have a deep learning
system there it it helps um uh the
endoscopist from missing um
polyps things like that that should be
um removed for biopsy
and um that's what most of the clinical
trials are about there's one on
childhood cataracts
that
helps to uh diagnose them and
lead to um
um optimal treatment and most of these
studies have positive outcomes the um
there's another study on out of hospital
cardiac arrest where they
developed a model for an algorithm to
assist with diagnosis and it actually
even though the algorithm worked pretty
well
it didn't make a difference in the
patient care the the um
patients in the ambulances to whom it
was applied um didn't do any better
whether they had the um
predictive algorithm or not
so um so again my my complaint about
this is this table is um almost unusable
other than creating a screen capture of
it which i've done here but you can look
at it in the paper um but um the uh
uh well i'll get to this in a second but
anyway so so this is what we have in the
world right now and and you know this is
about a year old now so maybe there's a
few more studies but 11 clinical trials
of deep learning so um we need to do
more
and i think there's opportunities for
people to do more
um so
uh what do what do we conclude about
this um systematic review
clearly
these tools show great promise if you
look at all of the modeling studies
that you know
people have built models now that
train
that can read
chest x-rays for tuberculosis for covid
for pneumonia as well as radiologists
can can read
electrocardiograms as well as
cardiologists
can
classify skin lesions as cancerous as
well as dermatologists
so we clearly have a lot of promise for
these algorithms but now
how do we actually apply them in
clinical
studies and and i think that's the next
big challenge
um and that may be where the world goes
beyond the data scientists to the
informaticians the clinicians and so
forth
these trials here in particular
also
have a high
indeterminate or high risk of bias
and and again the deep learning studies
are very focused on on essentially one
kind of procedure
uh so i do have a few concerns about the
review if it had come to me for peer
review which didn't um i might have
point these pointed these out i actually
the published paper actually has there's
actually a missing column um if you go
back i don't know if we can anyways um
i pointed it out to the author and he
acknowledged that it makes that that
table i just showed you challenging to
use he actually sent me a revised copy
but i don't think that's made it into
the paper yet
that also the table of machine learning
interventions is a problem that is
problematic because it's this huge
unmanageable pdf um that's like
basically a printout you know it's like
someone had a table in word and
printed it and it's it's impossible to
work with actually the author was nice
enough to send me his excel file which i
have if anyone wants um and as often
happens in systematic reviews um there
are studies that that are either not
present or
um perhaps they were classified
study by um
mute themselves who's talking please do
so
and and then they didn't system based on
the
thermometer i don't know who's is there
possible to mute whoever is
talking they're not i think they just
joined by phone they need to mute their
phones please oh okay
okay thank you for for muting
um
so
and they actually didn't provide a table
for the traditional statistical so it's
hard to know
you can't just get a nice overview of
those studies and what was done and so
forth so i i think there were some
aspects of the review that could have
been done better
so
um
anyways so one may ask
which department is best poised to
uh evaluate
uh
um these sorts of things and in fact if
any of you read my blog actually wrote
this uh actually this scott um
when the the nih was doing preparing
this bridge to ai
funding initiative they had this
workshop and they asked people for grand
visions and mine
i i called for a grand vision of what
kind of what i'm talking about here
translational ai it was one of the 25
that were picked
um
they didn't um that ended up being
completely separate from the funding
initiative which which we might get
funded with a group that we're involved
with um but anyways you know i think
that um
and maybe i
probably should have put david door here
instead of me but anyways
um
uh
d mice you know i i think we have the um
ability to to um to really do all
aspects of this work
so uh my so instead of stating
conclusions i'm going to ask other
people to state the conclusions and
maybe i threw up a few
questions and i i talked a little bit
longer than i thought i might um but um
what do people conclude from all this do
you agree with me do you disagree with
me um i will
um i don't know if uh actually there are
some things in the chat
um let's see
and then i can also
um
oh boy lots of um
uh save the date for the banquet um
the difference between not positive and
negative results um thank you mina
that's actually a good point um
uh
yeah
yeah yeah
right
um yeah they did now did the webex folks
just hear paul
no we didn't hear the question no we
didn't get a question yeah they didn't
hear the question okay well that you
know that is something we're going to
have to solve for this room um but uh
paul just kind of picking up on the
point that mina made um
um you know what are the actual outcomes
if if we actually uh can go
back
a
see if i can go back
if we go back to
just looking at the deep learning
um
they they looked at um
trying to see here trial outcomes
so for example this i'll just pick this
first one so mean blind spot rate
um
maybe that's not a real good one um
you know or the second one accuracy of
diagnosis um was uh an outcome
and and when they i assume that positive
means that the
group using the
ai tool
in this case maybe made the diagnosis
better
or um
detected like this one in the middle
here detected an adenoma better detected
a polyp better and missed fewer ones i
assume that for the endoscopy ones they
probably video recorded the whole thing
so it's those sorts of things and you
know i think ultimately
the outcomes should be
clinical
like um
you know can can we um advise people to
use
you know you should use
a deep learning algorithm connected to
your endoscopy tool to make sure that
you don't miss that polyp or something
like that
um and and then maybe that leads to
um
a cancer being detected earlier with
perhaps a better outcome
something like that
deb levy makes a very excellent point
as
i see that uh aaron is here aaron and i
are trying to get a negative
paper published um
there's definitely you know publication
bias as most of you probably know is
that studies that are positive are more
likely to be published um
or what was it that paul used to say
what is it uh well
interest
or david sackett quote
yeah
yeah so as paul just said studies with
enthusiasm usually lack control study
with controls usually lack enthusiasm
it is a challenge um in that um
you know and it's this is not limited to
ai you know people want to publish
positive results the new england journal
of medicine wants to be quoted
um
you know in in the washington post
tomorrow that you know a new study shows
that this tool
you know
makes you know helps uh identify cancer
earlier and patients have better
outcomes um or you know some cases you
know there was the big ivermectin trial
that was published in the new england
journal this week that i think it was
really exciting for them to say that
there was no benefit
anyways but
publication bias is definitely a problem
nina asking observational studies
can provide evidence of benefit um
why they chose um
you know i think um
it's definitely true that observational
studies
can give us lots of information but for
clinical interventions the the gold
standard
is a randomized controlled trial and so
that's why the authors i assume that's
why the author is limited to this
um
kate saying
statements like our study included more
ai
rcts than previous reviews probably true
um
okay um
uh gold standard
being experts that's true um especially
in studies of diagnosis
gold standard um
there
some have said there are truly no gold
standards in medicine
there's probably some truth to that
so
let me then go back to my um
in fact maybe let me stop
yeah
something like that so
i guess what is your sense
yeah no no that that's a great point um
and and probably since the folks on
webex didn't hear it um
that um
let's try to rephrase it the um that the
these
there are other benefits of ai that
occur further upstream
um
that
and and you know there are many
studies you know which i've alluded to
where people have developed models and
and we need to do those studies
because it's only the models that work
that should actually then
be used in the randomized control trials
because if the model doesn't work then
um
you're not really showing you're not
really using anything that's known to be
beneficial um i think the modeling
studies are are kind of like the basic
science studies that are done you know
in medical centers so in the basic
science departments here we have a lot
of people who do
um laboratory studies you know tissue
culture studies uh animal studies
compounds that are um you know
potentially useful
in
uh treating diseases and we do it with
you know
tissue cultures and animals first before
we move to humans
um and um
we learn a lot in that process we learn
a lot
we learn about something that might work
um or something that doesn't work
um and then when it does work it
advances
upstream downstream
i don't know which
but um but yeah so the the
the this no one
can or should conclude from this that we
should not keep doing we we need to keep
doing the modeling studies we need to
keep building the models and and testing
it with good data sets and there's a lot
of issues about getting the best
quality data sets um
but um you know that's that's the basic
science work um
and that work can also provide insights
you know so um for example um there's an
i don't know if it made it into this
well i guess it wasn't a randomized
controlled trial but there have been
some studies where they've taken large
um corpora of medical records and been
able to predict um deterioration in the
hospital
mortality things like that
very few of those
tools have actually made it to the point
where
they're actually put in a hospital and
someone
finds something about a patient and
intervenes and does something but you
can still learn a lot from those studies
you can learn about the kinds of things
the factors that are associated with uh
patients deteriorating in the hospital
and so forth
so
you know it's important to do those kind
of studies and and then um
you know and and have those advanced to
this level um so we can actually
see how effective they are i don't know
if that answers the
sort of yeah then
um you know i don't know if those epic
i do actually know a fair amount about
those epic studies so our um
the the vendor of our and many other
academic medical centers ehr system
um epic
has a bunch of proprietary prediction
models and
some of them have been shown to work
pretty well but um others have done
studies actually showing that they don't
work well
and because they're proprietary
they're obtuse um you know no one knows
you know why the model didn't work well
um i i don't you know i i assume
actually if there were randomized
control trials done using those models
they would probably be in the
traditional statistical ones because
those models are pretty basic
but as we know from studies that
you all and and me too are familiar with
those models have not been very
transportable
and part of it has to do with
um you know just the real world
implementation of epic and people not
defining the data fields properly and
has actually led to calls for these
kinds of models to be much more open and
transparent because we
can't
um you know when they
um if we're if we're gonna if we have
someone saying you know use this model
it's in epic but if we don't
know how it's been validated and so
forth then you know that's kind of like
using a drug you know to treat a disease
that we don't know how it's been
validated
yeah yeah yeah was there another hand up
over here yeah yeah it's hanging down
by looking at the hunger models
so there are there are 27 models already
yeah yeah so so um so we're
talking here about um
um models and and some of the
limitations um and um what and changes
talk about when you said 27 is that um
for coving yeah yeah the there someone
wrote a paper i i'd have to dig it out
but um
um
that you know
there's the data has been so plentiful
with kovid that anyone and their brother
can create a model and train it and if
it seems to work publish it um but
very few if any of those models have
been validated in in real world settings
and and actually shown to provide any
kind of predictive value for patients as
as i read that paper
so
um
let me see um
mustafa has a comment let's see if how
we can
work this you want to unmute yourself
and hopefully we can hear you
hello
i hope that the folks in the room can
hear me
um
i thought this was an interesting paper
and i was
intrigued by the framing of traditional
statistical methods versus
there's a distinction drawn between
machine learning and deep learning
when statistical methods do have
a way of doing deep structure which is
structural equation modeling
i didn't see
structural equation modeling in the
query
um
i looked up on and in the paper it said
most of the traditional statistical
methods were regressions
i looked up pubmed you know
structural equation model and
randomized controlled trial and i got
nearly 500 results
so
it just wasn't clear to me that that had
been in scope for this paper and it
seems like if it wasn't it was a bit of
an oversight and i'm also concerned that
the framing sort of implies that
statistics is of the past and data
sciences of the future when in fact
there could be a much more vibrant um
sort of information landscape happening
there
yeah i think those are great points um
you know i that that's why i had wished
actually that there was a table
like there was for machine learning and
deep learning of the traditional
um statistical it you know and actually
seeing some of the errors some of the
simple errors that i saw in this paper
makes uh always raises a concern
around um you know how well
peer-reviewed it was although
npj um you know is part of the nature
group someone would think that they
would have decent peer review of this
but you know this is what the peer
review process is for
um you know i uh probably others too
have reviewed papers um knowing that you
know pointing out to the authors that um
you know there's several papers you
missed here which makes us wonder about
your
uh methods for identifying all them so
that that would be um
um interesting to look at
um i i see some comments from from dr
vim about the the use of deep learning
to the endoscopy um i don't know
um
you know again i don't know the details
of of these particular studies but you
know you could go
um look at them i think that the models
were trained
they must have been trained using video
of some of these procedures but then how
it actually got applied in the clinical
setting um i you know we would have to
go in and look at the individual papers
um so
bill i i just uh look at a monty article
they are using that real time i thought
it was just experimental but i'm reading
an article that is a title uh the future
is almost here so we are using that live
during the endoscopy procedure so yeah i
found an article thank you so much for
this i didn't know that this is
happening
you know thank you so much i didn't
enjoy i'm very much interested in those
things
thanks okay well i i'm actually looking
at the time and seeing that we have um
run over um sometimes in
my enthusiasm i
uh
uh don't don't keep an eye on the time
but um anyways um i i hope actually you
know obviously there's probably a lot
more we can discuss i i hope that this
um conversation will continue you know
because um i i certainly see the the
benefit of all of the
ai research that's going on
and um
you know would like to see it
in my lifetime
actually make a difference clinically
and so hopefully we will see that so i'm
going to stop at this point and
thank everyone for their attention
thank you